as an attorney who often represents
women who accuse men of sexual
harassment or abuse especially in a
working context what's your reaction to
the governor of new york resigning today
well i think
it's been long overdue
for both this political and legal
reckoning for governor cuomo it has now
come
and he has resigned which is very good
it's what my client sherry ville
who was a victim of governor cuomo and i
uh called for
uh some time ago when we did a press
conference
where we talked about the fact that he
had grabbed her and that he had kissed
her that he had not asked her permission
to do that he did it inside of her home
and he also did it outside of her home
and he had said well this is what
italians do but his problem is
sherryville is also
italian and she said that's not what
italians do her family members do kiss
uh family members when they greet each
other they do not kiss complete
strangers and grab them by the face
somebody else's wife and pull them to
them and kiss them so yes i'm glad he
resigned
and this is very important
for the people of new york it's very
important because it's really a teaching
moment for others
other employers of course he was the
employer of a large state
uh workforce in new york
and it's also important for other
elected officials to know that they also
need to be accountable
in a lot of ways this feels like a
teachable moment as you said because
cuomo didn't even admit today that he
has sexual harassed anyone and it feels
to me like he wants to put this in the
political attack box right
but that's not the point here the point
is that he did he doesn't ask for
permission before touching people why
doesn't he seem to get that that that is
actually
required and that is a key point that
you're making because
you know how
it's just a
little moment that he would have to
pause and say is it okay if i hug you is
it okay if i kiss you is it okay if i
grab you wherever he's intending to grab
you know for it's been kind of male
privilege in the past to just do
whatever you want to women whenever you
want however you want it because you
feel like it and that's why
uh but you know women are not garden
statues they are actually human beings
who have feelings they have lives they
have families uh they need to have their
boundaries respected and their space
respected and someone just needs to ask
he has used his power his prestige his
influence to really take advantage of
those who have been very vulnerable and
powerless but now he can't use his power
and his prestige and his influence to
shield him anymore for the consequences
of his wrongful acts and so now he is
paying those consequences and that is
really what matters it's long overdue
i'm glad this day has come
uh my client sherry ville
uh is happy that he has resigned
my client susan uh ianucci with whom i
did the press conference today because
he used that video of her of his kissing
her in his video defense uh response to
the new york attorney general's report
uh accusing him of sexual harassment
and he didn't ask her if he could kiss
susan he didn't ask her if it was okay
to use her video in his video defense
uh it was not okay it painted a false
narrative because susan does not
appreciate what he did to her and she
certainly would never have consented to
be used as part of his defense but he
never bothered to ask that's wrong
and i want to add that i also it is uh i
represent the state trooper i also
represent the state trooper who uh whose
experience
is uh detailed in the new york attorney
general's report in reference to
uh
her experience with
governor cuomo
and she has authorized me to say that
she's glad he did the right thing today
by resigning
in a lot of ways that particular set of
facts
was
specific disturbing in a very specific
way because the state trooper carries a
gun
uh she's a member of law enforcement and
yet he felt emboldened and free enough
to treat her like an object
anyway do you think that that particular
fact pattern
can sort of pierce through
um some of this
uh
need for culture shift i think that's
one of the examples in the report that
stands out to me
well all i can say is
there is there there's been a cultural
shift and it's come into the juries uh
uh in civil cases and also in criminal
cases
uh in civil cases for example we see the
metoo movement having a huge impact
uh in a very famous sexual harassment
case that our law firm tried in 2019
where we sued a billionaire on behalf of
one victim of sexual harassment
and we won a verdict from a jury of 58
million
250 000
for one victim of sexual harassment uh
motion for new trial denied so a jury
was very very much in support of our
client in that case and for a different
victim of the same billionaire whose
name is alky david a few months earlier
our law firm tried another case and a
different jury awarded more than 5
million dollars to yet another victim of
sexual harassment in the criminal
uh area as well we saw harvey weinstein
in new york convicted
of
criminal sexual assault against
my client mimi haley who was the key
victim in the
criminal case in new york and he was
convicted of criminal sexual assault
against her and sentenced to 20 years
just on that charge alone
and then three or more years for another
victim of sexual harassment so
many years ago district attorneys would
never file criminal cases under these
facts and circumstances now
they
have made a judgment that they have a
chance of proving beyond a reasonable
doubt to a jury
that a person who is a predator who's
er
is going to convict if the right
evidence is uh is demonstrated to them
and admitted in court of law
so there definitely is an important
shift not only generationally not only
culturally
but now
into the legal sphere as well and what
does that all mean
means that governor cuomo has a lot to
fear about what may happen
even before his resignation i love after
his resignation
i love how you explain the impact of the
culture shift on juries and also um in
the civil and criminal context i think
that's extremely important for folks to
understand we're not just you know doing
culture shift for for the fun of it
uh there are important uh consequences
as a result gloria allred thank you so
much for joining me tonight and please
stay safe
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube you
can see more from zerlina by clicking
any of the videos on this screen and
make sure you subscribe below to stay up
to date on the day's biggest stories
thanks for watching